Open mHealth is a new nonprofit organization that promotes
greater access to mobile health data through an open standard and associated tools.
Similarly to FHIR, the open mHealth standard uses rest APIs
to access data package according to Json based Schemas.
Essentially, the equivalent of FHIR resources,
but with important differences because of the special challenges of mHealth data.
Here's an example of part of the open mHealth schema for blood glucose.
In FHIR, this would be an observation resource.
I have placed a part of one of those adjacent to it.
I used smart and FHIR's frame tool to create the sample resource.
The important point is that things included in Open mHealth but not in FHIR.
I've highlighted those in red here.
First, you see that the Open mHealth glucose reading can occur over time.
In this case, a four month period.
In clinical practice, it would be a point reading
usually when the patient is in the physician's office.
So, FHIR does not anticipate a situation like this.
As we said, mHealth data has special challenges.
And this illustrates one of them, volume.
A diabetes patient might document their blood glucose daily.
They see their physician every four months.
Does that physician want to see all 120 data points?
Almost certainly not.
So Open mHealth is indicated here might provide an average for the four month period.
For blood pressure, this might be the maximum and minimum over some time period.
Another mHealth challenge is data context,
when and how was data collected.
This should be clear in a physician's office,
but it may not be when the patient is at home.
Here, the Schema provides contextual information
showing that the patient takes their glucose reading upon waking and before eating.
Physicians usually do something similar when patients visit their office.
Calculated metrics illustrate another challenge,
the accuracy of mHealth data.
Step counts is a good example.
Fitbit provides a discussion of
their step count calculation approach that says in part quote,
"Fitbit trackers uses a 3-axis accelerometer to understand your motions.
By analyzing acceleration data,
our trackers provide detailed information about frequency, duration,
intensity and patterns of movement to determine your steps taken,
distance traveled, calories burn and sleep quality."
Of course, another device might receive different input from its sensors,
and might do the calculations somewhat differently.
To test the second point,
I have long had two activity tracking apps on my phone.
The numbers seem to vary by around 1 percent,
and the app with a higher number is not consistent.
My two apps are on the same phone,
so they presumably receive the same data from it.
This admittedly nonscientific comparison by
CNBC shows far greater differences in step counts
among nine wearable devices where
both a sensing technology and the calculation might be different.
I provide a link to an article from
The Journal of Personalized Medicine if you want
more details about the accuracy of mHealth data.
To better understand the rich possibilities of the standard and the in-house space,
I strongly suggest you spend time studying the Open mHealth schema library.
You can also further explore
the somewhat different perspectives of Open mHealth and FHIR.